ghost of sushi mus 1.05 patch just  released with lethal difficulty which  puts you in brutal combat with faster  detection speed  more aggressive enemies tighter parry  and dodge windows and attacks that kill  you one to two hits  we'll attack two camps while taking no  damage with expert hud on  and show you some tactics you might not  have seen before enjoy  [Music]  yes  [Music]  oh  oh  oh  be careful up there  what's up  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  the best day of my life my lord go  and stay safe  hear you  [Applause]  still  i've given up hope before you came  you're safe now  [Music]  hmm  me  [Music]  all right  thank you for saving us my lord we were  given this piece of armor and asked to  protect it  but i think it's much safer in your care  who gave you this  he didn't stay long enough to explain  strange  i'll look after it